PROFESSOR: So the idea behind
the encoder is increase the
minimum distance at the cost
of spectral efficiency.
The idea behind the decoder
was the following.
You have a received signal, y.
And the job of the decoder is
to find x hat, which belongs
to the signal set so that
you minimize your
probability of error.
And the probability of error
x is not equal to x-hat.
That's the probability of
error for your decoder.
And we saw a bunch of
equivalence rules -- we said
that the minimum probability of
error rule, which is this
rule here, is the same as the
maximum a posteriori rule.
And this just follows
by the definition.
This was the same as the maximum
likelihood rule.
And here we made one assumption
that all the
signals in your signal set
A are equally likely.
And this was shown to be
equivalent to your minimum
distance decision rule.
And in order to show this
equivalence, we use the fact
that the noise was White
and Gaussian.
So this assumes equi-probable
signals.
And this assumes AWGN channel.
OK.
In fact, the minimum distance
decisions has very nice
geometrical properties.
We basically said that the
decision regions had a
particular shape.
They were convex polytopes.
And they were also known
as Voronoi regions.
However, finding the exact
expression for the probability
of error seemed quite tedious
so we decided
to settle with bounds.
And we developed some bounds for
the probability of error.
And the main bounds were -- we
had a strict upper bound,
which was the summation.
OK.
This is a strict upper bound.
Well, the inequality here, say
it's a strict upper bound.
We also had a union
bound estimate.
Because this is a sum of various
Q functions, this is
still a very cumbersome
expression to evaluate.
So we wanted a simpler
expression.
So we then approximated this
by K_min of aj times Q of
d_min over 2 sigma.
OK, and now if we take the
average on both sides, what we
get is the probability of error
is approximately equal
to K_min of the constellation,
which is the average number of
nearest neighbors, times Q
of d_min over 2 sigma.
And this expression is known as
the union bound estimate.
We call it an estimate because
it's not a bound anymore.
We have made an approximation
going from here to here.
So this is what we came
up with last time.
Throughout the analysis today,
whenever we have a probability
of error expression, we will be
estimating it by the union
bound estimate.
So this union bound estimate
is quite important.
Are there any questions
on this?
OK, so today we will start by
introducing the notion of
effective coding gain.
And we'll use the symbol
gamma sub f for that.
What do we mean by effective
coding gain?
First you have to decide what
region you're operating in.
It's defined for both
bandwidth-limited regime and
power-limited regimes.
So let us start with the
power-limited regime.
Remember in the power-limited
regime, the trade-off we care
about is the probability of bit
error versus Eb over N_0.
The baseline scheme is 2-PAM.
And for 2-PAM, we showed two
lectures ago that the
probability of bit error is
given by Q of root 2 Eb N_0.
OK, it should be --
so now the idea is to plot your
probability of bit error
as a function of Eb N_0.
Eb N_0 is always plotted
in dB on the x-axis.
The probability of bit
error we also plot on
a logarithmic scale.
So this is ten to
the minus six.
This is ten to the minus
five, ten to the
minus four and so on.
The Shannon limit is at --
this is the Shannon limit --
is at minus 1.59 dB.
OK?
For the power-limited regime,
the performance of 2-PAM,
which is given by this
expression, is here.
And we basically go to say that
when the probability of
bit error is ten to the minus
five, the EbN _0 that you
require is 9.6 dB.
This is a nine.
So what's the idea behind the
effective coding gain?
Well, suppose I give you a
certain constellation, OK, a
certain signal set.
And you find the probability
of bit error for that,
and you plot it.
And it comes out to be
something like this.
So this is the performance for
some given signal set A. This
is your 2-PAM.
And now you want to quantify how
much better is the signal
set over the baseline system.
Now, so in other words you
want to look at the gap
between the two curves.
Now clearly the gap is going
to be a function of the
probability of bit
error, right?
But the basic idea now is you
want to fix a certain
probability of bit error because
if you're designing a
system, the probability of bit
error is something that the
system tolerates and is
going to be fixed
throughout the analysis.
So in this course, we'll
be fixing it at ten
to the minus five.
You fix this probability of bit
error to ten to the minus
five, and you look at how
much a gap you have
between the two curves.
And this gap is going
to be your effective
coding gain in dB.
So in other words, effective
coding gain, I can write here,
is the gap between a given
signal set and concordant
system, 2-PAM, at a fixed
probability of bit error.
OK?
So now let us try to quantify
this effective coding gain
using the union bound estimate
that we have here.
So if I have a certain signal
set, A, then I know from the
union bound estimate that the
probability of error is given
by K_min of A times
approximately Q of
d_min over 2 sigma.
So since I want that expression
in terms of
probability of bit error,
I will use the fact that
probability of bit error is
probability of error per
symbols or the number
of bits per symobl.
Since I have endpoints in my
signal set, I have logM bits
per symbol.
And this is then K_min of A over
logM base 2 times Q of
d_min over 2 sigma.
So I'm going to rewrite my
probability of bit error
expression now in this --
in fact the right side
in this quad.
K_b of A times Q of root
2 gamma_c of A
times Eb over N_0.
So I'm just going to define
the right hand
side in this way.
And I'm going to relate gamma_c
of A and K_b of A to
the parameters I have on the
right hand side there.
And why do I want to
do it this way?
Because I want to get an
expression as close as
possible to the performance
of an uncoded 2-PAM system
because that way things will be
easier to do if I want to
calculate the effective
coding gain, OK?
So how do the parameters
relate?
Well, K_b of A is K_min of A
over logM to the base 2.
And this is the average number
of nearest neighbors per
information bit.
If I compare the arguments
inside the Q function, what I
have is 2 gamma_c of A times Eb
N_0 is the argument d_min
over 2 sigma squared, which I
will write as d_min squared
over 4 sigma squared.
So remember sigma squared
is N_0 over 2.
So if I simplify this
expression, what I will end up
getting is gamma_c of A is
d_min squared over 4 Eb.
Gamma_c of A is known as the
nominal coding gain.
It's not the same as the
effective coding gain, which
is the distance between
the two curves.
OK, are there any questions
so far?
So far what I have done is given
a constellation A, I can
find two parameters.
I can find the nominal coding
gain, and I can find the
average number of nearest
neighbors per information bit.
And using these two parameters,
we will try to get
a handle over the effective
coding gain.
So that's the idea.
So how can we plot --
so given this constellation
A, we want to plot the
probability of bit error
curve like this.
But instead of plotting the
exact curve we will be
plotting this curve here,
which is the union bound
estimate of your probability
of bit error.
So we will always be plotting
the union bound estimate.
So how do we do that?
So we'll again start with
a curve like that.
Probability of bit error as
a function of Eb N_0.
This is in dB.
The y-axis is also in dB.
Sorry, not in dB but
on the log scale.
And so on.
This is the Shannon
limit at minus 1.
59 dB.
This is the 2-PAM performance.
So if we want to plot this union
bound estimate, you will
be doing two steps.
First, we'll be plotting this
Q function, a curve
corresponding to
the Q function.
And then we'll be scaling it.
So if I just want to plot this
Q function, how will it
compare to this curve here?
Well, you're just scaling the
argument inside the Q
function, right?
But now because we are plotting
the x-axis on a dB
scale, it simply means that we
are translating to the left by
an amount of gamma_c in dB.
Is that clear?
Well, let's see.
What we are doing is we are
going to scale the x-axis by a
certain constant.
So this means that we will have
to scale x-axis here.
But, our Eb N_0 is being plotted
on a dB scale, right?
So multiplying in the linear
scale corresponds to an
addition on the logarithmic
scale.
An addition on the logarithmic
scale simply implies a shift
on the x-axis so that's the
constant shift on the x-axis.
I'm going to plot it here.
This curve is going to be
parallel to the original 2-PAM
curve to the best
of my abilities.
OK, so this is what we get
as your Q function.
Now we are going to scale the
y-axis by this factor here,
K_b of A. But remember the
y-axis is also on a
logarithmic scale, rather
than the linear scale.
So multiply [INAUDIBLE] by a
factor of K_b of A implies a
vertical shift by a
certain factor.
So I'm going to do a vertical
shift here.
So let me make that
darker now.
So this is what I
end up getting.
OK, now note that the distance
between these two curves is
not fixed anymore.
If the slope is steeper, then
this distance is small,
meaning that this distance
here is large.
On the other hand, if the slope
is going to be smaller
here, then this distance
is large.
So this means that a distance
between these two curves is no
longer fixed.
And basically what we're saying
here is that if the
probability of error is large,
then the number of nearest
neighbors matters much more.
But if the probability of error
is going to be quite
small, then the more important
factor is your exponent, how
fast the slope decays as opposed
to the number of
nearest neighbors, OK?
This distance here is your
effective coding gain.
And this constant horizontal
distance here is your nominal
coding gain in dB.
Are there any questions
on this curve?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
on the right of four 2-PAM
because these are the logM.
PROFESSOR: So so what I'm
really assuming is that
gamma_c of A is greater
than 1.
So if I'm adding it, then
I'm going to shift
to the left, right?
OK, so a couple of remarks.
I'm just summarizing a few
remarks I made while
plotting the curve.
First is the log-log scale is
very convenient because any
multiplicative factor simply
involves a translation along
the x and y directions.
The second point is that the
accuracy we have in the
effective coding gain in this
way is determined by the union
bound estimate because that's
all we are plotting.
We are not really plotting
the exact curve.
And the third point is that
we have a rule of thumb.
Because the distance between the
curves is not fixed, it's
still too tedious to find the
exact numerical value of
effective coding gain.
So what we can find is the value
of the nominal coding
gain and K_b of A exactly,
given a constellation.
So we want to have a rule
of thumb for the
effective coding gain.
And the rule of thumb is that
the effective coding gain is
given by the nominal coding gain
in dB minus 0.2 log2 of
K_b of A. This is in dB.
What this means is every factor
of two increase is K_b
results in a loss of 0.2 dB in
the effective coding gain.
OK, and this is our probability
of bit error of
ten to the minus five.
So that's the region that we
will be doing our analysis in.
So this rule of thumb
is quite helpful.
Are there any questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This rule of thumb?
Well, it works quite well
in practice so you
want to use that rule.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
If things are clear, let
us do some examples.
So let us start with a
2-PAM for examples.
The first is 2-PAM system.
What's the effective coding
gain going to be for this
constellation?
It's going to be 0 dB, right?
It just follows from
the definition.
I mean the effective coding gain
tells us how much gap we
have between this new
constellation and 2-PAM.
If your new constellation is
2-PAM itself, we don't have
any effective coding gain.
What about the 4-QAM?
It's going to be still 0,
because a 4-QAM is a Cartesian
product of two 2-PAM
constellations.
And we argued last time that
there is no coding gain if you
use a Cartesian product.
If you want to verify it using
the framework that we have
just developed, say we
have four points.
This point is alpha, alpha.
This point is minus alpha,
alpha, minus alpha, minus
alpha, and alpha minus alpha.
The nominal coding gain
is given by d_min
squared over 4 Eb.
The minimum distance is 3 alpha
between any two points.
So we have 4 alpha squared.
Then what's the energy
per bit?
Well, the energy per symbol
is 2 alpha squared.
Then we have two bits per
symbol, so the energy per bit
is alpha squared.
So we have 4 alpha squared,
and so that's 1.
So we do not have any
nominal coding gain.
K_b of A, what's that
going to be?
Well, we have two nearest
neighbors per symbol, but we
also have two bits per symbol.
So the number of nearest
neighbors per bit
is going to be one.
So your nominal coding gain is
1, K_b of A is going to be 1.
And so we do not see
any coding gain
for the 4-QAM system.
Now let me do a slightly
different case.
Let me start with a 4-QAM,
but I remove two points.
I remove this point, and
I remove this point.
And I only keep the
two points here.
So I have a constellation, say,
A prime, which only has
two points, one point here
and one point here.
So this point is alpha, alpha,
and this point is minus alpha,
minus alpha.
Any idea what the effective
coding gain
will be for this case?
AUDIENCE: I think
it's the same.
PROFESSOR: It's still
zero, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because it's
saying that's 2-PAM.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
All this is a 2-PAM
constellation embedded in two
dimensions.
It's 2-PAM along this
line, right?
So I cannot hope to have a
higher coding gain for this
constellation over
the original one.
I mean I told you the story that
we can take a subset of
points, and we can increase
the minimum distance by
throwing away some points.
But one has to be careful
in that analysis.
There could be examples where
you're strictly improving the
minimum distance.
Note that the minimum distance
here is going to 8 alpha
squared now.
OK, so the minimum distance
is strictly improved.
But what happens to be
your energy per bit?
Well, the energy per symbol
is 2 alpha squared.
But you only have one bit per
symbol, so the energy per bit
is 2 alpha squared.
So your nominal coding gain is
d_min squared over 4 Eb, which
follows from the relation
we have here.
And d_min squared is
8 alpha squared.
4 Eb is also 8 alpha squared, so
the nominal coding gain is
1, or 0 dB.
The average number of nearest
neighbors, well, we only have
one nearest neighbor, and we
have one bit per symbol, so
that's -- and this is A
prime by the way --
is going to be 1.
And so the effective coding
gain is still 0 dB.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So probability of
symbol error as a function of
alpha has definitely
decreased, right.
But the trade-off we care about
is probability of bit
error as a function of Eb N_0.
In other words, this curve
is still here.
It's not changed.
I just shifted right by
reducing my spectral
efficiency.
OK?
So let's do one last example
just to prove that it's not
always the case that you get
nothing by removing points.
OK, so the contellation that
I have in mind is the one I
introduced last time.
We'll start with a 3, 4
Cartesian product of 2-PAM.
OK, so in three dimensions
it's a cube, and the 3,4
Cartesian product will
have a point on each
vertex of the cube.
And we only keep four points.
So the points we keep are
these four points.
OK?
So I write B, the coordinates
are alpha, alpha, alpha, minus
alpha, minus alpha, alpha,
minus alpha, alpha, minus
alpha, and alpha, minus
alpha, minus alpha.
So these are the vertices.
These are the coordinates of the
four points here where we
have the standard x, y and
z-axis, which I'm not drawing
because it will just
look confusing.
So now we'll see that for this
particular signal set, we do
have a coding gain, OK?
Let's find the minimum
distance.
The minimum distance
here is what?
It's the distance along
a diagonal.
And the diagonal is of length to
-- each side of the cube is
off-length to alpha.
So the diagonal is of
length to alpha.
So d_min squared is
8 alpha squared.
What is the energy per bit
going to be in this case?
Well, what's the energy
per symbol now?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 3 alpha squared
over 2 is the Eb, right?
We have 3 alpha squared units
of energy per symbol.
We have four points, so we
have two bits per symbol.
So the energy per bit is
3 alpha squared over 2.
So now if I look at my nominal
coding gain, that's going to
be d_min squared over 4 Eb.
d_min squared is 8
alpha squared.
4 dB is 6 alpha squared.
So that's 4/3.
On a linear scale and on a dB
scale, this is going to be?
You guys should remember
your dB tables.
AUDIENCE: 0.2?
PROFESSOR: 12.
You have to multiply by ten.
So actually I think it's 1.3,
more like 1.3 dB if you look
at the last significant digit.
OK, so what's K_b of A going
to be in this case?
Or K_b of B I should say.
I'm calling the signal
set B here.
So what is K_b if
B going to be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 3 by 2, right?
You have three nearest neighbors
per point, for each
point has three nearest
neighbors.
They're all equidistant.
And you have two bits
per symbol.
OK?
So if you work out your
effective coding again using
this rule of thumb here, take
gamma_c of A in dB and
subtract 0.2 log2 you will see
that the effective coding gain
is approximately 1 dB.
Are there any questions?
OK, so it might seem that
this is still not a
very impressive number.
Yes, you had a question.
AUDIENCE: What was it about this
constellation that gave
us coding gain?
Was is the face that we went
to higher dimensions?
PROFESSOR: Right, so usually
you do get a coding gain if
you trade-off minimum distance
with spectral efficiency.
So that's usually the case.
So that's why I presented you
an example of that case.
It's just that this was a very
special case where you end up
with a 2-PAM constellation
to start with.
OK, so the comment I was going
to make is that 1.2 dB still
might not be like a very
impressive number.
I mean after all the hard
work, you just get 1 dB
effective coding gain.
So the question to ask at this
point is are there any
constellations that have much
higher coding gains?
In particular, other
constellations that come close
to the Shannon limit at all.
And we'll look at one
interesting class of signal
sets, which are known as
orthogonal signal sets.
And you probably saw these
examples back in 6.450, but
we're just reviewing
it again here.
And these signal sets have a
property that as you increase
the number of dimensions, you
come arbitrarily close to the
Shannon limit.
So the definition of the signal
sets is your A --
it's a collection of signals aj,
where j goes from 1 to M
such that the inner product
between ai and aj is E A times
delta_i,j, meaning that if i
is not equal to j, the two
signals are orthogonal.
And if i equals j, the
energy is E(A).
Geometrically, we
have two points.
The two points can be
thought of as two
points on the two axes.
So this is a case
when M equals 2.
When M equals 3, the three
points will lie on those three
corresponding axes.
So this is the case when
M equals 3 and so on.
So generally when you have
M points, your signal
spatializes in M dimensions, and
each point can be thought
of as a point on one
of the axes.
So if you look at the distance
between any two points, it's
the norm of ai minus
aj squared.
I could simplify this simply as
the norm of ai squared plus
the norm of aj squared because
the end product
is going to be zero.
OK, now ai squared is
going to be E(A).
aj squared is going
to be E(A).
So this is 2E(A).
So what we're saying here
is that every point is
equidistant from every other
point, and the square of the
distance is 2 E(A).
OK?
So in other words, the average
number of nearest neighbors is
always going to be
a M minus 1.
So let us calculate the nominal
coding gain for this
constellation.
That's going to be d_min
squared over 4 Eb.
d_min squared is 2E(A)
over 4 Eb.
Well, the energy per bit is the
energy per symbol, which
is E(A) over the number of bits
per symbol, which is log
M to the base 2.
And this I'm going to write
here is 1/2 log
M to the base 2.
So as I increase my M, my
number of dimensions, my
nominal coding gain
goes to infinity.
OK?
What do we expect for the
effective coding gain?
Will it also go to infinity?
AUDIENCE: It approaches
the Shannon limit.
PROFESSOR: Well, we don't know
whether it approaches the
Shannon limit as of yet,
but we know it
cannot go to infinity.
It's upper bounded by
the Shannon limit.
Right?
So the effective coding gain
cannot really become
unbounded, and what's really
happening here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, but why does
the effective coding gain stay
bounded and the nominal
coding gain blow up?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, the number
of nearest neighbors also
increases with M, right?
Not just the nominal
coding gain.
So let's write that down.
If I look at the number of
nearest neighbors per
information bit --
yes?
AUDIENCE: These don't
have 0 mean, right?
PROFESSOR: Right, they
don't have 0 mean.
That's a good point.
PROFESSOR: Let's see, what
happens to the mean as M goes
to infinity?
If we look at what happens to
the mean, it will be 1 over M.
You find the mean of this guy,
it's 1 over 2 times the
distance here times distance
here is 1 over 2 E(A), E(A).
OK?
If you look at three dimensions,
it's 1 over 3
E(A), E(A), E(A).
So in M dimensions, it's going
to be 1 over M times all these
coordinates.
If we look at the mean squared,
it goes to 0 as M
goes to infinity.
So that's a good point.
So the mean does go
to 0, and so we
approach the Shannon limit.
So we have K_b of A over
logM What's the
number of nearest neighbors?
We saw it was M minus 1 over
log M. And that goes to
infinity as M goes
to infinity.
OK, so the average number
of nearest neighbors per
information bit also
go to infinity
as M goes to infinity.
And if we look at the mean --
just to write down the comment
that was made.
If we look at the mean of this
constellation, that's going to
be 1 over the number of points
times root E(A) root
E(A) and root E(A).
So there are M coordinates.
So that's going to be the mean
if you believe this is the
coordinate axis here.
And if you we look at the norm
of M(A) squared, then it's
going to be E(A) over M. And
as M goes to infinity,
this goes to 0.
And because the mean goes to
0, it's not unreasonable to
expect that the performance does
approach to the ultimate
Shanon limit.
OK, so so far we have looked at
K_b of A and gamma_c of A.
If you look at the
effective coding
gain, it is still bounded.
It's always bounded.
It is not clear at this point
what really happens to it.
And in fact, it's not quite
straightforward to actually
show what happens to the
effective coding gain.
If you have taken 6.450, then
Professor Bob Gallager really
goes into the details of proving
how the effective
coding gain for this signal set
indeed does approach the
Shannon limit.
But it can be shown that the
effective coding gain does
approach 11.2 dB as M
goes to infinity.
The main trick here is that
union bound is usually quite
weak if the probability
of error is small.
So we replace the probability of
error just by 1, instead of
the union bound,
at some point.
And if you do that change, then
things work out nicely.
But in this course, we will
just assert that the
orthogonal signal sets
do achieve the
ultimate Shannon limit.
And you can see 6.450
notes for the proof.
So that's the assertion that
we are making right now.
So let's step back and
take a look at what's
happening so far.
We have a class of signal sets
which are conceptually quite
easy to describe.
They are just orthogonal
signal sets.
They are not too hard
to analyze, and they
asymptotically approach the
ultimate Shannon limit.
So this seems quite nice.
So why not we just
implement them?
Now it turns that these are not
very common in practice.
They are not implemented as
often as you might think when
you first look at
them and because
they have some drawbacks.
And there are a couple of
drawbacks which make them very
less appealing than what you
might otherwise think.
And first of all, what's the
spectral efficiency for these
signal sets?
AUDIENCE:0, right?
PROFESSOR: It goes to 0.
And how does it go to 0?
It's 2log M to the base 2 over
M. As M goes to infinity,
this goes to 0.
And in fact, it goes
to 0 quite sharply.
Now that's fine, but if you
want to approach Shannon
limit, our spectral efficiency
should indeed go to 0.
But if you're looking at the
system design problem, what do
you really want?
You have a certain effective
coding gain that you have in
mind, and suppose you are
presented with a list of
several different signal sets
that achieve this effective
coding gain.
And your job is to pick one of
these possible signal sets.
Which one will you pick?
Well, there are two things
you will look for, right?
You will look for the spectral
efficiency that these
different signal sets require
or achieve in order to get
this effective coding gain.
And the higher the spectral
efficiency the better.
And secondly, you will also
want to look at the
implementation complexity.
You do not want something which
really takes a lot of
time to decode.
OK?
So it turns out that because the
spectral efficiency goes
to 0 so sharply, it's not very
surprising that there are
other codes that have the same
effective coding gain but
higher spectral efficiency.
So there are binary codes that
have a higher spectral
efficiency for same effective
coding gain.
And so they would be a natural
choice over the orthogonal
signal set.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
high-spectrum efficiency to
mean bandwidth?
PROFESSOR: Right, because in
practice, bandwidth is never
really infinite, right?
So if you are achieving
the same --
the first objective is
to have a certain
effective coding gain.
If you do have that, you want to
pick something which has a
higher spectral efficiency.
And indeed, the subject of
chapters six and eight is to
come up with binary codes that
have a much better performance
than the orthogonal signal
set for a given
effective coding gain.
Chapter six deals with the the
block codes, whereas chapter
eight deals with convolutional
codes.
And chapter seven basically
develops all the finite field
theory that you require to study
convolutional codes.
So the point is, in the
subsequent lectures we will be
focusing a lot on improving
the performance over
orthogonal signal sets.
The second point I mentioned was
implementation complexity.
Now one particular way of
implementing orthogonal codes,
which you saw in the first
homework, was using this idea
of Hadamard transforms, right?
You have a Hardamard matrix,
which is an M by M matrix.
The rows of the Hadamard matrix
are your orthogonal
signal sets, which
are elements aj.
And at the receiver, what you
would do is when you get the
signal y, you simply multiply
by the Hadamard matrix and
look at the coordinate
which is the largest.
So this is something
you did in the
first homework exercise.
And how many computations did
you require for an orthogonal
signal set of size M?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
OK, so I meant M being
the size of the
orthogonal signal set.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: 2 to the
M by 2 to the M.
PROFESSOR: If it is 2 to the M
by 2 to the M, it is M times 2
to the M. But there are M
orthogonal signal sets, then
it will be M log M, where M is
the number of signal sets.
So that's the number
of computations
that you would require.
Now, the question to ask is, is
this fast or is this slow?
Is this too many computations
or is this too little
computations?
And if you're looking in the
power-limited regime, what we
really want is to see the
complexity per information bit
because we normalize things
per information bit.
Now, how many bits are sent
when you have orthogonal
signal set of size M?
We have log M bits, right?
So this quantity is actually
exponential in the number of
transmitted bits that we are
sending, and so in fact this
is quite slow.
Or in other words we are saying
it is we require M
times 2 to the M computations,
where M is the number of
information bits that
we are sending.
AUDIENCE: So if M is the size
of your [INAUDIBLE]
then you have log M bits?
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: So M log M
over log M is M.
PROFESSOR: Why are
you adding by M?
AUDIENCE: You need M log M
operations to decode a symbol.
PROFESSOR: To decode a symbol.
AUDIENCE: And each symbol
gives you log M bits.
So you have M operations
per bit.
PROFESSOR: Well, when you send,
say, log M bits, right,
you can only send one of
the M possible symbols.
And when you want to decode the
symbol, you would end up
recovering log M bits.
So you should not be
dividing by M here.
AUDIENCE: You're dividing by log
M because you want to do
it per bit.
PROFESSOR: All right.
You're right.
So you're dividing by log M.
You have M log M bits.
You're dividing by log M,
so you still have --
AUDIENCE: You have M
calculations per bit.
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So we are sending
-- so I need this many
computations to get
log M bits.
So is this expression
exponential in log M or not?
So that's all I was saying.
AUDIENCE: I just put it another
way that you could
divide by log M.
PROFESSOR: M for information,
right.
OK, are there any questions?
I mean we are both agreeing to
the fact that this is too many
computations than
you would want.
And there exist other decoding
algorithms for which the
number of computations is much
smaller than exponential.
OK, so let's next look at the
bandwidth-limited regime.
Well, actually before that I
wanted to mention a couple of
other signal sets as well.
So there are two other important
class of signal sets
which are related to the
orthogonal signal sets.
The first is this class of
simplex signal sets.
And the other class is
bi-orthogonal signal sets.
So the idea behind simplex
signal sets goes back to the
observation that was made that
we have a non-zero mean for
this signal set here.
So if we do, we can indeed
subtract of the mean and get a
performance which is
better than the
orthogonal signal set.
So in particular if I subtract
of the mean here, I get a
signal set, which
is like this.
This is the simplex signal
set when M equals 2.
When M equals 3, I'm going to
subtract of the mean from this
plane here.
The points lie on this
particular plane.
And what I end up with is
an equilateral triangle.
So this is the case
when M equals 3.
What do you think M equals
4 would look like?
A tetrahedron right here.
That's a simplex signal set.
So basically, it's also not too
hard to write an algebraic
expression for these
signal sets.
E of A prime is going to be
E of A minus M of A. You
subtract off the mean from your
orthogonal signal set.
If I want to write it in terms
of inner products, the inner
product between ai and aj is
given by E(A) if i equals j.
And it's I believe minus of 1
over M minus 1 times E(A) if i
is not equal to j.
So this is the inner product
between ai and aj.
And I mean there are also many
properties of this simplex
signal set, but I believe that
that's going to be in your
next homework exercise
so I'm not going
into too many details.
What' the spectral efficiency
in this case going to be?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So what is a simplex?
Is a simplex just a reference to
anything with [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Simplex signal set is
derived from the orthogonal
signal set by subtracting
off its mean.
AUDIENCE: Right, but in general
simplex means anything
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I'm not
sure about that.
What's the spectral efficiency
going to be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, almost.
AUDIENCE: You use
one dimension.
PROFESSOR: Right, you just
use one dimension.
OK, and there are other
properties that you'll be
looking at it in the homework.
Now the idea behind this --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This is 2 log
M over [INAUDIBLE].
So the idea behind the
bi-orthogonal signal set is
you start with an orthogonal
signal set, and for each
point, you also put the
negative signal of it.
So in addition to this, you will
have a point here, and
you will have a point here.
So the case in two dimensions, M
equals 2, you will have four
points like this.
So in this case you are
increasing the number of
signal points by a
factor of two.
But this does come at
a price, right?
Because if you're increasing the
number of signal points,
the number of nearest neighbors
is also going to
increase by a factor of two.
In this case, you have two
nearest neighbors now.
So you have both of the
effects going on.
I mean ultimately, all the
signal sets, as M goes to
infinity, are going to approach
the Shannon limit.
So again, but they do suffer
from the same kind of
drawbacks that we saw for the
orthogonal signal sets.
So these are more of theoretical
interest as
opposed to real, practical
implementation points.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Minus [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It's a bit
involved to show.
I think you'll be showing it
in the homework exercise or
for an exam problem
at one point.
You basically start with the
orthogonal signal sets here,
look at the inner product here,
and use the relation
between the simplex signal sets
and the orthogonal signal
sets to do a subtraction
of the mean.
And then you can derive in
a product expression.
OK, so let's now move on to the
bandwidth-limited regime.
OK, so the main difference
between --
yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: You mean here?
For each --
AUDIENCE: How far can
you [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: A factor of two.
I said a factor right?
So if you have M points in the
orthogonal signal set, you
have 2M points in the
bi-orthogonal signal set
because for each --
AUDIENCE: In the orthogonal
sets you have 3.
PROFESSOR: And in
this you have 6.
So let's look at the
bandwidth-limited regime.
The trade-off we care about is
the probability of error for
two dimensions as a function
of SNR norm.
OK?
The baseline scheme here
is your M-PAM scheme.
And we showed a couple of
lectures ago that the
probability of error for two
dimensions is approximately 4
Q times root 3 SNR norm.
OK?
So let's plot the performance
graph.
So on the x-axis I
plot SNR norm.
On the y-axis I plot Ps of E
again on a log-log scale.
This is ten to the negative six,
ten to the negative five,
ten to the negative four,
ten to the negative
three and so on.
The intercept is at 0
dB, this point here.
So this is your Shannon
limit in the
bandwidth-limited regime.
Now your performance curve is
going to be something like
this for the M-PAM system.
And we want to basically
quantify now the effective
coding gain in this regime.
So it's the same story as in
the power-limited regime.
We will start off with the
probability of error using the
union bound estimate, which is
K_min of A times Q of d_min
over 2 sigma.
Now Ps of E is the probability
of error for two dimensions.
Assuming we have N dimensions
here, it is two times the
probability of error over N.
So this is probability of
error per symbol.
We are dividing by the number of
dimensions and multiplying
by two because it is
for two dimensions.
And this is going to be 2 times
K_min of A over N, times
Q of d_min over 2 sigma.
So now let's do the same trick
that we did in the
power-limited regime.
We will write Ps of E
be approximately --
and instead of the right hand
side, I will write it as Ks of
A times Q of root 3 SNR norm.
But because I have a factor of
four up there, I will also
multiply and divide by 4.
That's not going to
change anything.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
per two dimensions
or by symbol.
PROFESSOR: Per two dimensions.
And for bandwidth-limited
regime, we normalize
everything by two dimensions.
AUDIENCE: But for N band we used
it for symbols, right?
The calculations represent --
PROFESSOR: No, it was
for two dimensions.
OK?, so now let's compare
the two expressions.
We have Ks of A, which we'll
define by two times K_min of A
over N. And this is the number
of nearest neighbors per two
dimensions.
And I can write 3 times SNR norm
is d_min squared over 4
sigma squared, OK?
Actually, I was missing
this factor of gamma.
I knew I was missing
something.
It's not just 3 SNR norm.
It's 3 times this nominal coding
gain times SNR norm.
So 3 times SNR norm times
gamma_c of A here.
So this is d_min squared
over 2N_0.
So what do I have for the
gamma_c c o A is d_min squared
over 6 N_0 times SNR norm.
Remember SNR norm is SNR over
2 to the rho minus 1.
It's normalized signal-to-noise
ratio.
So this is the d_min squared
times 2 to the rho minus 1
over 6 times N_0 times SNR.
But N_0 times SNR is just Es.
So this is 6 times Es.
So this is the expression
you have for the
nominal coding gain.
So now again, given a signal
set A, I can find those two
parameters, the nominal coding
gain and the number of nearest
neighbors per two dimensions.
And I can use those to
plot on the Ps of E
versus SNR norm curve.
Again, the exact same story.
If I have a certain nominal
coding gain, I will simply
shift my curve around the x-axis
by that factor as a
pure translation.
And then because I have a factor
of Ks A over 4, I'm
going to plot --
how did that expression go?
This expression on the top.
Remember this curve here is 4
times root 3 SNR norm, right?
So the multiplicative factor
I have is Ks(A) over 4.
So I will shift my curve
up by that factor.
And I will get something
which is like this.
And that's my union bound
estimate for this new
constellation A.
The distance here is
gamma effective.
This distance here is gamma_c of
A. Are there any questions?
So now we also have a similar
rule of thumb as in the
power-limited regime.
I will write that rule
of thumb here.
We have that gamma effective is
going to be gamma_c in dB
minus 0.2 times log2 times
Ks of A over 4 in dB.
OK, so again, a factor of 2NKs
will decrease your nominal
coding gain by a factor
of 0.2 in dB.
Are there any questions?
Well, so I mean this is the
end of chapter five.
We still have like ten minutes
remaining, so I thought I
would give you a preview
of the next chapter.
Professor Forney will be coming
next class, and he will
be starting chapter six
all over I believe.
This chalk is much nicer to
erase than that other one.
So in chapter six, we'll
be looking at the
binary block codes.
OK, and what is the main
architecture of these codes?
Well, for an encoder, remember
we have K bits coming in.
And we pass it now through
a binary block code.
And what we get out is
a binary sequence
of length N. OK?
So x belongs to c, where c is
a subset of binary sequences
of length N.
So we start with K bits, and
we convert them to N bits,
where N is going to be greater
than or equal to K. Once we
have this sequence of N bits,
what we end up doing is we
pass it through a binary
signal constellation.
So I'm writing in as
binary signaling.
And what we get out is
S of x, which is a
sequence of N symbols.
Each symbol can either take
value minus alpha or alpha.
So this binary signalling is
actually quite a trivial step.
Basically, the relation is S of
0 is going to be alpha, S
of 1 is going to
be minus alpha.
If I have a 0 coming in, I
will produce an alpha.
if I have a 1 coming in, I will
produce a minus alpha.
So this part here is trivial.
All our energy will be
focused on will be
to find a good code.
Given a sequence of input bits,
we want to find a good
binary code in order to
optimize the minimum
distance and so on.
So that's the architecture that
we will be using for the
binary linear codes.
Both chapters six and
eight will be only
focusing on this part.
And this binary signalling
scheme, for the most part,
will be implicit in
our architecture.
So at this point, one might ask
is there anything to lose
in having imposed this
type of architecture?
Remember, the nice thing about
this architecture is we have
coding, which is going on here,
and we have modulation
that is happening here.
And the modulation step
is quite simple.
So we have a separation between
coding and modulation.
OK?
And the question is, is this
the right thing to do?
Now, it turns out that if we
are going to live in this
binary world where we are only
constrained ourselves to
sending binary signals over the
channel, this is in fact
an economical structure.
There isn't much improvement we
can get, and that is quite
obvious, right?
But it turns out that if you are
going to go for non-binary
signaling, particularly in the
bandwidth-limited regime,
there is a cost to be paid for
this kind of separation.
In fact, in the 1980's there
was this whole idea of
turbo-coded modulation or
trellis-coded modulation.
And the idea there was to
combine coding and modulation
in one step.
So this is not optimal for
non-binary signalling, but's
it's OK for binary.
So we will be focusing on this
type of an architecture.
The other issue is OK, nobody
told us that you can only send
binary signals over
the channel.
If you want to achieve the
Shannon limit, when we derived
the capacity expression --
or we just stated it but
you can derive it.
We said that the Shannon
limit is always less
than log2 1 plus SNR.
And we never said that we can
only send binary signals over
the channel.
So it could be that this is some
inherence of optimality
in this type of architecture.
Why send binary signals
in the first place?
Again, it turns out that the
regime that we are interested
in here is the power-limited
regime because the spectral
efficiency can never be more
than two bits per two
dimensions, right?
Remember, rho is 2K over N here,
and K is going to be
less than that.
So we are inherently in the
power-limited regime.
And so a natural thing to do
in order to understand how
much fundamental loss we have
in imposing this type of
binary constraint over the
signals is to not look at this
expression, but to find the best
possible performance we
can have if we constrain
ourselves to binary signals
over the channel.
If we impose a certain signaling
constraint, we can
find another fundamental limit
on the spectral efficiency.
So the point being, the best
possible binary code can only
achieve this upper bound here.
Now, this upper bound
has to be less than
log2 1 plus SNR, right?
Because the Shannon code assumes
the binary signaling
is a special case.
So it turns out that this
expression is actually quite
tedious to write out.
I'm not even sure if the
closed-form expression exists,
but you can calculate
this numerically.
It's just some kind of a convex
optimization problem.
And now, to understand how
much loss we have, we can
compare the two expressions in
the power-limited regime.
So I'm going to plot the curves
for the two cases.
I'm going to plot the spectral
efficiency on the y-axis as a
function of Eb N_0.
You can easily convert from
SNR to Eb N_0 using the
relations we discussed
in chapter four.
Now we first plot the
Shannon limit.
The ultimate Shannon limit
is minus 1.59 dB.
This is going to be 0 dB here.
And if I'm plot the Shannon
limit, it will be
some code like this.
It increases with Eb N_0.
And minus 1.59 dB is 0.
This point here is 1.
Some point here is 2.
So actually I want to draw this
horizontal asymptote at
two when rho Shannon equals 2.
So this is my rho Shannon.
Now, I can now also plot
rho binary from
this expression here.
I can never exceed two bits
per two dimensions.
So I had plotted this
horizontal line.
So as Eb N_0 goes to infinity,
the most I can get is two bits
per two dimensions.
If Eb N_0 is smaller, I cannot
do better so I will be doing
worse and worse, and I will
always be below this line.
Ultimately, it can be shown
that I will have the same
Shannon limit here.
So this is rho binary.
And the main observation here is
if I'm in the power-limited
regime, which is say, in this
part of the curve --
like, say around one bit per two
dimension -- the gap here
is quite small.
In fact, this gap can be shown
to be at most 0.2 dB.
So if I want to achieve a
certain spectral efficiency,
if I impose a binary signaling
constraint, the additional Eb
N_0 that I require when the
spectral efficiency is 1 dB,
one bit per two dimensions,
is at most 0.2 dB.
So there is not much to lose by
imposing a binary signaling
constraint.
Said in different words words
if you had the best possible
binary linear code, followed
by a binary signaling
constellation, the most you
can lose is 0.2 dB.
And so this type of an
architecture does make sense.
There are a lot of details that
the next powerpoint will
be to kind of formalize the
notion of a binary block code,
then specialize it to the
case of binary linear
codes and so on.
Unfortunately, the first thing
to do is to start with some
finite field theory because
there's a lot of finite field
algebra involved in this
algebraic block codes.
So how many of you have seen
finite field theory before?
OK, if you haven't seen it,
don't worry about it.
We'll be starting right
from the basics.
But I think I will be stopping
here for today because I don't
want to go into those
details today.